father i have come here on your business
not mine
because of this lord i ask you to grant
me your spirit
when you send moses to egypt to speak to
pharaoh he was going on your business
and so you said to him in exodus chapter
4 12
now therefore go and i will be with thy
mouth
and teach thee what thou shalt say
father i ask you from my heart
teach me what i should say
and let the truth find a secure lodging
in the hearts of those who have come to
hear i
offer this prayer as your son in jesus
name amen our subject
is all or nothing
all or nothing
it has been my casual but alarming
observation
that most christians including
a distressing number of seventh-day
adventists
do not believe that it is possible
through the power of christ to arrive
at a place in one's christian walk where
one
absolutely refuses to sin
now we have examples in scripture of men
who prefer to die
rather than sin despite this evidence in
the flesh
we stubbornly resist the biblical
knowledge
and teaching that full
victory over sin is not simply possible
it is required
when considering jesus christ and what
he came to do for us
no one questions the fact well i should
say virtually no one
questions the fact that jesus was fully
god
we swallow that no problem
but we gag
when we consider that jesus was fully
man
despite what we read in hebrews 1 which
presents him as fully god
and hebrews 2 that presents him as fully
male
we need to understand that jesus fully
understands the father
because he was just like him in nature
so he holds the father with one hand
that he holds on to divinity
he fully understands us because he
became like us so he can hold us with
the other hand
he understands divinity he understands
humanity
and humanity and divinity meet
in jesus christ
jesus came like you
and like i am with the weaknesses
the passions the struggles we have
which is the heritage of those born
from adam he came with the ability to
feel
he was compassed with our infirmities he
was touched
with the feeling of our infirmities why
that he now having
understood and felt what we
feel having met us where we are
he can lift us up so that we
can meet him where he is
having won the victory in our skin
let me say that differently having
lived as we lived having suffered
temptation
as we suffer temptation having said
no to the tempter consistently
and having won the victory through his
father
because he says in john 6 57 as the
living father hath
sent me and i live by the father so
he that eateth me even he shall live by
me jesus is saying
the same way i am sustained by my father
you should be sustained by me
and how did the father sustain him fully
how is jesus willing and ready and able
to sustain us if we will permit him by
faith
fully
in genesis chapter 28
reading verses 12 and 13 as we continue
all or nothing
now usually in the evening service i
tell you i let you out at 8.
but since i started about 7 32 33
i cannot conceivably release you from my
custody
at eight so i will release you
around eightish how is that that could
be ten o'clock
eight ish we love to tell we love to say
ish i'll be there ninish tennis
you know god is not an issue god
god says in the when the fullness of
time was
come let me digress as i always do
you know god is serious about time
god does not believe in being late
all late comers say amen
god is always on time and i love him for
that
and because of that i have tried my best
to be on time i was ministering in
africa last november
i was staying a little hotel on the
shores of lake victoria and they'd come
for me to take me to the tent
and i was trying to teach my brothers
how to be on time so i would leave my
hotel room
if i told them be there 5 15 i would
leave the hotel room
walk out in the street stranger i don't
know where i am and stand
at the corner and when they came for me
they felt so badly
that the guest was out of the street and
they were trying to get there on time
god bless them and i love them
but i had to show them i was not joking
i would stand
in the street that was my way of
teaching them christians
must be on time when you are on time
people learn to trust what you say
you learn you become reliable in the
eyes of people you can depend on that
man to be
where he says he will be that's the way
god is genesis chapter 28 reading verse
12.
as we continue with all or nothing it's
20 minutes to eight
and he dreamed and behold a ladder
set up on the earth and the top of it
reached where to heaven which means
the ladder was in contact with the earth
and it was in contact with heaven
it wasn't in contact with the earth and
close to heaven
it touched the earth and it touched
heaven and verse 12 goes on to say and
behold
the angels of god ascending and
descending upon it
and behold the lord stood above it and
said i am the lord god of abraham thy
father
the god of isaac and he spoke to jacob
who was the one sleeping
that ladder of course represented whom
jesus christ
he touched the earth that cursed ground
remember genesis 3 17 cursed is the
ground
for thy sake that ground that ladder
touched
representing jesus christ and it also
heaven jesus understands divinity
he understands humanity and he knows how
to get humanity
to partake of the divine nature
let us look at some texts that describe
the relationship between jesus
and his father let's go to john chapter
verse 21 john 5 verse 21 as we continue
all or nothing john 5
21 the bible says for as the father
raiseth up the dead and quickness them
even so the son quickeneth whom he will
in other words
the same way the father
has the power to raise the dead the same
way
the son has the power to raise the dead
let's look at verse 27 also of john 5.
for as the father hath life in himself
so hath he given to the son to have life
in himself
the same way life is natural to the
father life is natural to the son
let's go to john 10. let's read verse 15
i hope you're writing these verses down
john 10 reading verse 15 as you search
for that text let me encourage you from
time to time say a prayer for me
because i am human only jesus can speak
perfect truth and all i need you to say
quietly not out loud is lord give him
the right words to say that's all be
with his mouth
put the words in his tongue that's all
you say from time to time quietly
short prayer and god will hear your
prayer and i will feel the effects
john 10 15 as the father
knoweth me even so no i
the father the same way he knows me
i know him which by the way is an
argument for the
deity of christ because the father
knows christ christ says i know him the
same way he knows me because christ
knows
everything about the father the way the
father knows
everything about him christ is
equal with the father these three texts
show us
john 5 21 john 5 27 john 10 15
that as the father is so is the son
now the relationship between the father
and the son must be reflected in the
relationship
between us and the father
john chapter 17 let's read verse 11.
as we continue all
or nothing john 17 verse 11
and now i am no more in the world and
these are in the world and i come to
thee holy father
keep through thine on them those whom
thou has given me that they may be
warned how
as we are the same way
the father and the son are united in
heart and spirit and mind and ambition
direction plan and purpose we must be
the same way
with jesus now let's look at that
let's look at the concept of forgiveness
let's go to ephesians chapter 4 reading
verse 32.
we're looking at forgiveness god forgave
how should we forgive
my sister in the front to my right says
fully and she's right
let's read it ephesians 4 32 and be
kind one to another tender hearted
forgiving one another what's the next
word there
even or the same way
even as god for christ's sake has
forgiven you
we must forgive the way god or the
father forgives
same way and as the father does it so
does the son
the same way jesus forgives we must
forgive
that's the concept of forgiveness no
difference
we cannot say because i have the fallen
nature
i can't forgive the way jesus forgave
the fallen nature
is not an excuse for backing off from
the divine standard of forgiveness
we must forgive the way god forgives
and that standard is placed upon human
beings
and god only places a requirement on a
human being
if he knows the human being can achieve
it by his power
let's look at lifestyle first john
chapter 2
verse 6 as we continue
all or nothing first john chapter 2
verse 6 who has said to prayer for me so
far lord give him the word
god oh god bless you and i mean that
from my heart
god bless you
first john chapter 2 verse 6
he that saith he abideth in him ought
himself
also sought to walk what's the next word
even as he walked meaning the walk there
means the lifestyle
if we say we are god's children we abide
in him we love jesus and we say that
very easily in many languages
we love jesus the bible says if we say
that
we are to live the way jesus lived
we are also sort of walk even as he
walked what i'm trying to hammer into
your heads
is that the standards that guiding the
life of christ
must be the standards that guide our
lives
let's look at well we looked at unity in
john 17 11
that they may be won as we are
let's look at humility was jesus humble
oh yes oh yes let's go to john
13. john 13
the continuous all or nothing
reading from verse 13 of john chapter
13.
the bible says you call me master and
lord and ye say well for so i am
if i then your lord and master have
washed
your feet ye what ought also to wash
one another's feet for i have done what
given you
what an example that ye should do
how as i have done to you
the humility that i demonstrated in my
life says jesus christ
i require of my followers
because my followers must be just like i
am
in character
let's look at obedience
john chapter 15 verse 10
as we continue with all or nothing it's
either all of christ
or none of him we cannot serve christ
partially because the question has to be
asked
who has the other part
are you willing to answer that well
don't
we cannot serve god partially
if a man or woman is not wholly under
the control of christ
that person is under the control of
another power
let me speak my words again carefully if
a person
is not holy w-h-o-l-l-y
entirely completely under the control
of jesus christ by the agency of his
spirit that person
is under the control of another power
and there are only two
you have john 15 you have verse 10
what are we looking at now obedience
if ye keep my commandments
ye shall abide in my love what's the
next word
even as i have kept my father's
commandments
and abide in his love
jesus is saying that which kept me
consistently
in the love of my father will keep you
in my love and that was what give me one
word starts with an o ends with an e
obedience the obedience
christ requires of us differs not a wit
from the obedience the father required
of christ
let's look at love we love to talk about
love
you know some people say love god and
just do what you like
let's look at love how should we love
john chapter
15 reading verse 12 as we continue
all or nothing
i should tell you i'm reading from the
king james version for those of you who
are following
john chapter 15 reading verse 12
this is my suggestion that you love
one another as i have loved you
what's the standard by which we should
love what's the standard
the way christ loves is that a
recommendation
what is it a command
what should we do with commands how fast
quick you see a commandment isn't based
on how you feel
when the bible says love your enemies
you don't have to work yourself up to it
you obey immediately
the same way you obey it shall not kill
don't work yourself up to it obey
immediately
this is my commandment that you love one
another
as i have loved you and he goes on to
make that very clear
greater love hath no man than this that
a man laid down his life for his friends
that's how we love if
necessary we die
for each other and it was necessary for
jesus
and he died for us
and demonstrated his love
where people are persecuted christians
die for one another
all the time that concept is not foreign
there are soldiers dying for each other
in iraq and wherever else they're
fighting
we've looked at forgiveness we've looked
at lifestyle
we've looked at unity we've looked at
humility
we've looked at obedience we've looked
at love
central to our message let's look at
overcoming now what is it we're supposed
to overcome
say it again everyone let's look at how
christ overcame
and how we should overcome
since i last asked you who has prayed
for me
thank you and may god of abraham
isaac and jacob bless you
overcoming revelation chapter 3
verse 21 as we continue
the subject all or nothing it's now
eight minutes to eight
revelation 3 21
when you have leisure read the letters
to the seven churches
very eye-opening to him
that overcometh will i grant to sit with
me
where in my throne
now follow me my reasoning my
unseen visual aids to him
that overcometh will i grant to sit with
me
in my throne what's the next word
even as i also overcame
and i'm sat down with my father where
on his throne now these are the times i
wish i had a chalkboard i never asked
for it so it's my fault as usual
but use your imagination there are two
columns one right here
one right there to him
that's him that overcometh overcometh
will i grant to sit with me in my throne
that's jesus throne so we have him
overcome jesus
throne even as i
that's jesus also overcame
and i'm sat down with my father on his
throne so we have
him overcome jesus throne jesus overcome
god's throne did you see that
one person saw it anyone else saw that
it's in the verse let's read it again
read it with me
all king james owners read with me to
him
that overcometh will i grant to sit with
me
in my throne even as i also overcame
and i'm sat down with my father in his
throne now let us learn
something about the throne of the father
and the throne of the son
each has a throne revelation chapter 22
let's read verse one
as we continue all or nothing revelation
chapter 22 verse 1.
if you have a friend who can't find the
books of the bible please be a good
samaritan
and help that person
you have revelation 2 1 and he showed me
a pure
river of water of life clear as crystal
proceeding
out of the throne of and of the
two thrones look at verse 3.
and there shall be no more curse for the
what
throne of and of the shall be in it
two thrones
in john 10 30 what does jesus say i and
my father are
one what does that mean quickly
they are equal they're one not one
person
one in power one in might one in a deity
one in eternality if i can make a word
they are one in power they are one
now if they are equal in power
does one have a higher throne than the
other no
reason with me here's a good time that i
should pray that god will open your
understanding
to him that overcometh
i grant to sit with me in my throne
which is equal to what the father's
throne
even as i also overcame how many
overcomings do we have
two name them ours
and christ's now are the thrones the
same
yes the overcoming
that put christ on the father's throne
must be the same as what the overcoming
that does what
puts us on the throne of christ
because the thrones are the same
equal in power
so when jesus says even as i also
overcame he is saying
i expect my followers to overcome sin
the way i overcame sin i expect my
followers
to overcome the world the way i overcame
the world and he tells us how
in john 6 57 as the living father hath
sent me
and i live by the father so he that
eateth me even he shall live by me
same thing
it is an insult to god
to believe and a greater insult to
spread that belief
that it is impossible to overcome sin
all you do and all i do if we hold these
views
is that we advance the cause of the
kingdom
of darkness because if we believe that
then the logical extension is we must
say there are some sins
that we must commit and if that's the
case then we can choose the ones we want
to commit
the only safe way to deal with sin
is to see it as something we can
overcome
completely in our lives
that is what christ came to do
when the angel appeared to joseph
matthew 1
in verse 21 he said and she shall bring
forth a son
thou shall call his name jesus
why for he shall
save his people
from their sins
now i can bombard you with texts and i
probably will so you can write them down
now i mean that prove this point
jude verse 24 jude has this one chapter
so you just give the verse not the
chapter
now unto him that is able to do what
now give me yes or no
can god keep us from falling yes or no
from how many sins all
to doubt that is to doubt god
and without faith
whatsoever is not of faith is sin
let me say that again jude 24 now
unto him that is able
to keep us from falling and to present
us
faultless
the problem is not whether god can do it
the problem is
whether we want it
very few christians are attracted to the
possibility
of sinless living because christians
tend to view sinless living
as the highest expression of boredom
because the way the world works that
which is exciting is that which
displeases god
that's why i said earlier today unless
someone is convicted to the point of
conversion
what i'm saying makes no sense
when god spoke to jesus spoke to
nicodemus in john chapter 3
he said in verse 5 verily verily i say
unto you except a man be born of water
of the spirit he cannot enter into the
kingdom of god
then he said verse 6 that which is born
of the flesh is what
flesh but that which is born of the
spirit is what
spirit and when a man or a woman is born
of the spirit
that person desires the things of the
spirit
now unto him that is able to keep you
from falling
to present you faultless before the
presence of his glory with exceeding
joy why deny god the joy
of seeing us victorious it gives
god joy don't you understand jesus
endure the cross
for the joy set before him and the joy
wasn't seeing sinners say you can't save
me
the joy was the victorious people who
would accept jesus christ
the joy set before him the joy was so
great he took the cross
sometimes they tell me well there's a
channel that shows a
childbirth when the child is
the nurse says push push and the
mother's
face loses all her beauty and she pushes
her face all twisted into a mask of
misery
and when the child is placed in her arms
there is a different face on that mother
it's as if there was no pain at all
and she kisses that child and hugs that
child won't let the husband touch it
for the joy set before mothers they
endure the pain
over and over again
and god is no different for the joy set
before jesus christ
he endured the cross and the joy was the
victory
that people would win through faith in
his sacrifice
jesus didn't come give his life to
provide a partial victory
god cannot take a partially victorious
person to heaven
because that part that is not victorious
will cause trouble
are you listening to me and the bible
has said
iniquity shall not rise finish it
the second time and god's word will not
return
unto him void
and this business of iniquity shall not
rise a second time god does not force
a sinless world on us
a sinless world is god
signing off on the choices we make now
let me explain that differently
god will put us in a sinless world
because even before we get to the
sinless world we would have decided but
our lives
we want nothing more to do with sin
god cannot force you into a sinless
environment if that's not what you want
we must decide now in this sinful
environment
that we want to live sinlessly
as a sort of a divine rehearsal
for life wherein dwelleth righteousness
jesus came to save us
from sin
every sin first john chapter 1 verse 9
if we confess our sins
he is faithful and just to forgive us of
our sins
and to cleanse us from the serious ones
looking for that blessed hope and the
glorious appearing
of the great god and our savior jesus
christ who gave himself for us
that he might redeem us from all
iniquity
and purify unto himself as zealous
people
our peoples peculiar people zealous unto
good works
titus 2 13 14 15
all iniquity not some
i asked this morning i believe this
morning no
another group i spoke to at seven how
many sins does the bible record that
adam committed
one
how many sins are needed to cause
trouble in the new world
one
how big was adam sin
a vegetarian picks a fruit
someone said a vegan and look at where
we are
it doesn't have to be murder and
homicide and
genocide and ethnic cleansing and these
kinds of things
you simply have to stand in disobedience
to the least of god's requirements
and if that little leaven
remains in the lump
what happens to the lump the whole
lump is leavened my beloved brothers and
sisters
we must ask god
to give us hatred for sin
it's the first promise in scripture
genesis 3 15 and i will put what enmity
between thee
meaning the serpent and the woman and
between thy seed and her seed it shall
bruise thy head
and thou shalt bruise his heel i will
put
enmity hatred for sin
is not something we produce what is the
medical term
endogenously is that it
exogenously from the outside it does not
come from the inside
it must come from the outside
because love for that which is wrong is
natural to the nature
with which we are born that is why we
need to be born again
not just improve jesus christ didn't die
to improve us
a lot of people come to jesus to get a
little touch up here a little dry wall
here
a little paint here no jesus didn't do
that i heard someone say
when jesus comes if your life is a house
christ doesn't come with paint and a
broom
he comes with a bulldozer
and removes that house
on the land on which it sat and then
constructs a brand new house
that's the new birth nothing
from the old structure removed
completely so that if any man
be in christ he is what a new creation
and that creation
is one that loves to do god's will
god desires you and me to enjoy
victory over sin
if you don't think sin is a bad thing
read the final chapters of all four
gospels
and see what sin did to god
jesus christ read luke 23 2
verse 43 i believe and see what you've
never seen before
a man sweating drops of blood
why because of your sin
and mine
walk up that hill and see what no one
had ever seen before
the son of god
hanging on a cross
a spike through each hand and through
his feet
crown of thorns on his brow several
rivulets of blood flowing down his face
perhaps dried
and he's hanging there groaning because
he was human
human beings grown
and why for you and for me
and people passed by and mocked him
don't do that the chief priest passed by
and mocked him don't do that the roman
soldiers at the cross who nailed him
they mocked him don't do that
there's no longer cross on which he
hangs physically
but we can mock him by making light of
his sacrifice
saying that that sacrifice can only
deliver me from
white lies cannot deliver me
from an addiction cannot deliver me
from one terrible sin or the other we
make a mockery
of all that suffering
that jesus endured let me tell you
something jesus deals with us
individually
when he was suffering he saw you
and when he saw you he did not see me
standing next to you
he saw you and that was it
he saw me and that was it
and this evening christ looks down
from where he is in the most holy place
interceding on our behalf
and he wants to see
who will commit themselves
to seeking through his grace
victory over sin
let us show christ the bible says the
eyes of the lord are in every place
are they here now yes
any man any woman who will say lord
help me by your enabling grace
[Music]
to resist sin even if
i have to sweat great drops of blood
let me resist by the power that enable
jesus christ
raise your right hand
god bless you that comes from my heart
hands down
someone here will say preacher
i believe you but i have had a struggle
for years
that makes it so hard for me to believe
that i can overcome
and i need divine intervention
raise your hand
god bless you god bless you god bless
you
i want you to come right over here come
quickly come quickly right over here
a special struggle that has gone on for
a long time i
need divine intervention come right over
here
god bless you for moving so quickly
it's 12 minutes after 8 we'll finish on
time i need
divine intervention
well since we're so many let's just fill
up the front it's okay
just come forward let me assure you that
the angels are here to receive you
and it was the spirit of god that
brought you
anyone else i need divine
intervention
russell for years
anyone else
god bless you
i won't delay it but i'll take a
reasonable amount of time
it's the sabbath hopefully we have no
urgent things to attend to anyone
else
god bless you
someone else get up god bless you
bless you sister and you and you and you
and you
god bless you i mean that from my heart
god bless you
god bless you my dear sister
god bless you let's be very
serious i mean a seriousness that will
cause the angels to be quiet
god bless my brother coming on the
center aisle
i've been struggling i need divine power
anyone else someone else should come
god bless you someone else
god bless you god bless you come
god bless you my good brother god bless
you god bless you
god be with you as you come
and make sure this is a time for us to
all pray in our hearts that god will
soften hearts that are resisting
a very critical time to pray
i like to say this is not a spectator
event
this is very serious
god bless you as you come
anyone else
god bless you
and you my sister and you
and you god bless you
someone else that i have something else
to say
come sister god bless you
and you and you
god bless you
god bless you sister god bless you
god bless my sister to the left
god bless you my sweet sister god bless
you if it's a little uncomfortable to
stand you may sit
i've already seen you standing god bless
you
appeal number two
there are people here for various
reasons
need to make a decision a serious one
to be baptized you need to do that
and i'm speaking for christ who got
baptized he wants you to do it
not for your mother's sake your father's
sake
for his sake when he went to the jordan
to be baptized john the baptist said no
jesus said suffer it to be so for thus
it becometh us
to fulfill all righteousness baptism is
an act
of righteousness
those of you you know in your heart you
need to make that decision to be
baptized or re-baptized
i want you to leave where you are and
come up here with me
leave where you are and come right here
make room for my people who are coming
and i'm not just talking to those who
came to the appeal i mean those sitting
as well
you know you need to make that decision
leave where you are
i'm right here god bless you
god bless you
stand right next to me
someone else there's a way to come this
side as well
you need to make a decision
to be baptized or re-baptized if you had
left god you drifted so far
broke the covenant come
and make that decision
and i pray and let us go
god bless you my dear sister who else
someone else come
let it through
god bless you my beloved sister come
right up
someone else now i don't know your name
so i can't call it but god knows your
name
and as he touched these he is touching
you
get up and come
it's the right thing to do and the
righteous thing to do
who else
in obedience to christ i will decide
to prepare for baptism who else will
come
and i hope people are praying
and i'm about to pray
i will give exactly 60 seconds
then i'll pray 60 seconds begin now
you come for baptism
45 seconds
god bless you god bless you
25 seconds
let my brother come through
15 seconds
five
every head bowed every eye close
those seated could you kindly stand
father in heaven
in the quietness of this moment
i come to you on behalf of my brothers
and sisters
father a relationship with you is not a
game
you are best left alone if someone does
not want to serve you
all the way
to my first appeal there god many of
your sons and your daughters came to say
i have struggled i need divine
power over one thing or the other
lord you've said in first john 5 14 and
this is the confidence that we have in
him
if we ask anything according to his will
he heareth us father a request
for power to overcome is according to
your will
and we ask you lord to stand by your
word
and give us the power you gave to christ
father i know you're willing to do this
but we must be willing to do what jesus
did by
holding on to you by the study of your
word
by confession of sin by
prayer by fasting a
constant struggle the power to overcome
coming from you lord put into our hearts
more hatred for sin we don't hate sin
enough
we hate some sins but on all sins we
want to come to the place
where we hate all sin because all sin
put christ on the cross
and so father we come with the honesty
we can muster and we
say that we want to overcome we want to
hate sin
and we want our lives to be examples of
the transforming power of jesus christ
and so far in his name we ask you in
mercy
grant us that enabling power that we
need
pour into our hearts beginning now pour
it in a
hatred for sin a
deep and a perfect hatred for sin and a
love for all that is righteous meaning
all that pleases you
father the time is short our eyes need
to be open but our eyes have been
blinded by sin
open our eyes we pray that we may see
the danger our souls are in
oh father in heaven some have responded
to the call for baptism
and they're standing on either side of
your man's servant
father i placed them in your hand
tonight
because your word says none can pluck
them
from my hand and so god i place them
in your hand as treasures
and i ask you in the name of jesus lord
to sustain them
because the enemy has already begun
drafting plans to get them to change
their minds
but give them the divine wisdom to know
that the decision
they have made is absolutely right
father i am praying as their brother
and i'm pleading as your man's servant
sustain them give them a spiritual
backbone that will not bend in the face
of the most
the gusting winds of temptation let them
stand strong
that satan may be embarrassed as he
deserves to be
and god honored and glorified as you
deserve
for the other standing back father i ask
you to bless them
grant them more of your spirit increase
all of our appetite for your word
for that which is holy for that which is
right
bring us to the place where we can say
like jesus our savior in john 8 29
he that has sent me is with me the
father hath not left me alone
for i do always the things that please
him oh father let us find our greatest
joy
in pleasing you let us leave this place
believing
stubbornly that by the power available
to us
which worked in christ we can gain the
victory
over sin father we're sorry for having a
half and half relationship with
you we apologize
forgive us lord don't hold a grudge
father
please forgive us fully and
freely wipe the slate clean
let us leave this place determined by
your power
to walk with christ as christ walked
with you
this is our prayer we're offered in the
victorious name of jesus christ your son
and our savior
that all god's people say amen and amen
god bless you